in 1914 all of these countries in europe
were ruled by monarchs and these were
ruled by monarchs of a german royal
family quite a lot and given that some
of these rulers could trace their houses
back a thousand years and others mere
decades why were so many of them german
so a lot of this can be explained by one
thing the late unification of germany at
the turn of the 18th century the
german-speaking parts of europe weren't
unified like the french english or
spanish-speaking parts it was divided
into numerous smaller states many of
which had their own monarchies and these
monarchs would marry off their kids to
whoever would have them a prussian
princess married the prince of orange a
brunswicker duchess married the king of
denmark obeyed and duchess married the
king of sweden and one from mecklenburg
married the king of the united kingdom
given that all of these monarchies only
really paid lip service to their
overlords the holy roman emperors there
wasn't much risk in marrying them
whereas marrying someone in the french
royal family could cause issues with
inheritance which france unlike the
small german states could press and over
time childless or females would mean a
near relative would succeed the throne
and they would be a member of their
father's often german house but what
about countries individually well the
united kingdom's monarchy had previously
been anglo-saxon french welsh and
scottish after a flirt with catholicism
english nobles called upon william of
orange to seize the throne from james ii
he did and catholics were then banned
from becoming ruler william also didn't
have any children and so the throne went
to his sister-in-law anne she continued
the streak of not having an heir and
died childless and so the throne passed
to her cousin's son george of hanover
her closest protestant relative thereby
beginning the hanoverian dynasty which
would be succeeded by the sax coburg and
gotha dynasty which would soon after
change its name to winter when all
things german suddenly became less
popular in denmark throughout most of
its history its monarchy was an elective
one but when king christopher iii made
the mistake of dying without an air the
nobles had to pick somebody new as such
they chose christian who was the son of
the duke of sleshvig a region with a
sizable german-speaking minority which
denmarked a close relationship with and
one it wanted to keep this began the
house of oldenburg which still rains to
this day and also in norway although
norway chose the danish prince for their
throne when it split from sweden in
1905. the german and austrian imperial
families both have their origins in the
holy roman empire the hoe and zollans
were from zollin here and the habsburgs
were unsurprisingly from habsburg here
in what's now switzerland both slowly
over the centuries increased their
holdings and titles from counts to dukes
to archdukes and kings before emperors
there wasn't a lot of opportunity for
outside royal houses to advance in the
holy roman empire and so these families
just stayed german the last major power
which had a german royal family was
russia peter the great was a romanov as
was his daughter empress elizabeth the
first she died childless and the throne
passed to her nephew peter iii peter's
father was the duke of holstein and thus
he was a part of that house now peter
and his wife catherine kept the name
romanov to tie themselves to their
empire and its people and that royal
family stayed in power until you know a
thing happened so what about all of
these smaller nations well these nations
all came into existence in the 19th
century with the oversight of the great
powers who as a result got to choose who
would be king the first was greece
britain france and russia all had a
stake in the new country and thus they
all wanted an ally on the throne as such
after their first choice said no they
picked prince otto of bavaria who wasn't
aligned with any of them next was
belgium which as a buffer state between
prussia and france couldn't be aligned
with either as such the british shows
leopold of sax coburg and gotha husband
of the king's niece to keep the two
close to ensure belgium's independence
romania had a german monarch after its
first ruler a native romanian became
somewhat despotic and was overthrown in
a coup the new country had only recently
broken away from the ottoman empire and
so to maintain its independence its
nobles picked a prince from the prussian
hoen's olin royal family this
essentially guaranteed their
independence from russia the ottomans
and the austrians next door and for
bulgaria the reasons were similar at
first it was ruled by the nephew of the
russian emperor but he got himself
overthrown after being terrible he was
replaced by an austrian-backed candidate
which unlike romania was fine because
austria-hungary wasn't on the border
with them and after this these royal
families remained in place until either
today or their eventual ousting in the
20th century i hope you enjoyed this
episode and a special thanks to my
patrons james bissonette kelly money
maker skye chappelle caution wolf jerry
landon jordan longley adam stalter
marcus arsenault ryan hockey spencer
lightfoot rod d martin words about books
podcast captain cydog gustav swan marvin
castle common yoon winston k wood gilly
wiggly daniel to be in miss iset matthew
shipley aaron the white corey turner the
mcwhopper alex schwinn anthony beckett
coppertone maggie patzkowski schuenin
spinning three plates and charles the
first